good morning local elections don't
always seem very consequential but the
set of elections that we've just had
across the united kingdom could have
very big consequences for the future of
the prime minister and the very makeup
of the country that he leads well in
northern ireland shin fein won the most
votes and the most seats in the assembly
and it means that there are now real
questions about its future in the united
kingdom
north of the border in great britain the
snp managed to take even more seats
ahead of a possible independence
referendum there next year and meanwhile
given losses in scotland wales and
particularly the south of england many
in the conservative party will be
reflecting on whether boris johnson
really is the man to lead them into the
next general election
lots to discuss with our guests this
morning
well for the conservatives we'll be
talking to the deputy prime minister and
justice secretary dominic raab
for labor will be joined by shadow
levelling up secretary lisa nandy
meanwhile it was a pretty good night for
the lib dems they took seats from the
conservatives in the south so we'll be
talking to the party's deputy leader
daisy cooper
what about those conservatives
considering boris johnson's future we'll
also hear from senior tour mp tom
teugenhatz
meanwhile the war in ukraine continues
of course and as finland considers a
historic application to join nato we'll
be talking to the country's ambassador
to the uk yuka sukasari
[Music]
well there is no doubt that thursday was
a bad night for the conservatives the
party lost almost 500 councillors and 11
councils and those losses were of course
to labor in london and to the liberal
democrats in the south and if and it's a
big if of course the sort of voting that
we saw is replicated in the upcoming
general election the conservatives would
lose their majority in parliament so
what does the prime minister do now once
again to reset his government we're
joined now by his deputy and the justice
secretary dominic raab thank you very
much for
being with us this morning i'm keen of
course to get to those local election
results but i just want to start off
with what's happening in northern
ireland yeah it does feel like quite an
astonishing uh story shin fein winning
that historic victory sending their
first minister to the northern ireland
assembly what's your reaction
well look at there is a a
clearly some change in northern ireland
i think above all what we want to see is
the uk government is some stability i
think for the people of northern ireland
whichever way they voted
we want to see
an executive form the parties to come
together to provide the people of
northern ireland with that stability i
think it's equally clear that that
stability
is being put at risk imperiled if you
like by the problems with northern
ireland protocol that's something that
affects communities across the board and
it it's clear from the dynamic we now
see that we won't get to that position
of stability until and unless it's fixed
and so we're focused on those two
elements bringing the parties together
stability but also unlocking the
problems with northern ireland protocol
unlocking the problems with the northern
ireland protocol you sound as if this is
a something that you've got no control
over this northern ireland protocol was
what you imposed
well uh if it had been
implemented with the kind of flexibility
goodwill and with the
the business interests of communities
across northern ireland
and it hadn't been used frankly as a
political device in the way that that it
has
i don't think we'd have the same level
of problems but the the point of
discussing that has passed we must see
it now fixed the government is committed
to fixing it we won't get the stability
that i've talked about the political
stability and that's clear as a result
of the outcome of the elections in
northern ireland it's very clear isn't
it the dep
leader has uh said that effectively they
are not going to they'll collapse power
sharing they won't form part of the
executive until the uk government deals
with the protocol this is what jeffrey
donaldson said the protocol is harming
our political process it is undermining
political stability i made clear during
this election that the government needs
to sort that out and until they do i
will not be nominating a minister to the
executive i just want to sort of pause
and reflect on how serious that is you
know the executive can't function
otherwise they're in the middle of a
cost of living crisis well it hasn't
been an executive for some time as you
you know sophie so we want to see an
executive up and running we want to see
the parties come together in the kind of
corporation that can make that happen so
when you look at the protocol in the
next in the queen speech i just want to
get a bit of a timeline on this the
queen's speech next week is the protocol
going to be looked at then well you know
that i can't reveal details of the
queen's speech in advance but what i
would say is first of all we want to see
an executive that can serve the people
of northern ireland the bread and butter
issues of which of course during the
local elections in northern ireland many
people will be voting on as well as
other issues
but it's clear the northern ireland
protocol must be fixed the foreign
secretary's talked about it the prime
minister's talked about it and that
cannot be put off um because we won't
get the stability that we want we won't
get the executive that the people of
northern ireland need until it is dealt
with so how are you going to deal with
it
well look at the uh preferably by
negotiation but if not we'll have to
take the measures uh to make sure that
the
economic integrity of the trade between
northern ireland and the rest of great
britain and frankly the constitutional
integrity
of the united kingdom is protected and
preserved and we've talked about that we
set out a series of measures so this
isn't a new conundrum or problem uh
brandon lewis and the prime minister set
out in a command paper the kinds of
things that we would need to see happen
but we will deal with the situation we
will take whatever measures are
necessary to protect as i said the
economic as well as the constitutional
integrity of northern ireland but
fundamentally that northern ireland
protocol is not working for communities
right across the piece in northern
ireland and you hear uh that from
businesses and uh from communities
across the political spectrum so it does
need to be fixed so you do it
unilaterally without the eu if necessary
oh we've been clear that that option has
not been taken off the table we prefer
to get it resolved through negotiation
that's why
we've been through a protracted period
to try and get it fixed through
negotiation but of course as you know
there are measures that we can take
to make sure that we deal with the
problem we can't put it off and it's
clear now and in fact if anything the
outcome in northern ireland from those
elections makes it clear it can't be put
off and you say it can't be put off what
kind of time frame are we talking about
here well i don't want to jump the gun
because that will lead all the headlines
i think it needs to be dealt with very
responsibly but we've been talking about
we're talking weeks we're talking months
what no longer than that uh it must be
dealt with no longer than
weeks and i mean weeks and months you
know that can span a long period of time
i i want to i do not want to escalate uh
some of the tensions that we're seeing i
want to de-escalate them and that means
encouraging the parties to come together
um it was interesting to see the results
across the board uh in particular for
example the uh the results of the
alliance which very much campaigned
across community divides on bread and
butter local issues i think that's what
the people of northern ireland want to
see focused but the problem is the
stability that allows a northern ireland
executive to get up and running allows
uh the elected politicians to serve
those communities can't happen until we
unlock and fix the northern ireland
protocol
okay um i want to talk to you a bit
about um
the
the potential of a border pole as well
shin fein of course uh the largest party
they are obviously would have to enter a
power sharing agreement but this is what
the president of shin fein said
mary lou macdonald the president of
champaign she said i believe the
referendum and this is on a united
island i believe the referendum would be
possible within a five-year time frame
but much more importantly i believe the
preparation
needs to start now
what is quite a caveated statement um
but the point i'd make is that if you
look at the results in northern ireland
58 fully of people voted either for
parties who support the union or for
parties who do not support
constitutional change and that is the
message from the people of northern
ireland but what is the uk uh government
position on a border pole well look we
don't have an executive
yet
i think the first priority as i said i
mean mindful of that 58
of people in northern ireland who are
not calling um
for that kind of change is to get the
executive up and running get the
stability bring the parties together and
make sure we fix the northern ireland
protocol i think frankly those that is
what the people in northern ireland will
expect right now okay i'm keen to talk
about some of the election run results
elsewhere now uh in england scotland and
wales and just to
get a bit of a picture of what happened
with the conservative party so this is
what happened in england
and i just i'm focusing on the blue
column here the conservatives you lost
339 seats
in england alone we can go on to
scotland
in scotland
you lost 62 seats in scotland hard won
seats in scotland of course under ruth
davidson and in wales you lost 56 seats
in wales as well i mean this is a pretty
disastrous set of results well look um
they're challenging for any government
mid-term uh we see these kind of i'm
just going to come in you say that it's
challenging for every any government
midterm right the conservatives have
been in power for 12 years yeah when
gordon brown was in power after 12 years
in office he lost 291 is a lot better
than you and also we all know what
happens next we i don't think it's fair
to just write this off as midterms no no
i'm not i take it very seriously i know
i was out on the doorstep myself i know
the kind of
issues that were raised and of course
are very varied but all i'd say is um if
you look at kierstama's result in these
local elections yes um uh they've been
difficult for us but uh he did worse
than for example had miliband in 2012 no
cut through really beyond london we have
had a mixed bag results there's no sugar
coating it but we've also got areas in
the north um from uh harlequin barnsley
to bolton and in the south whether it's
basildon um uh or thorac where we've
done better than expected so yes it's
been difficult set of results but i
think the real story coming out of all
of this and and
politicians will be going all the sunday
shows making their pitch picking all the
different councils where they've done
better exactly so let me let me quote
two very impartial people sir john
curtis
and professor michael thrasher who said
respectively that labour's performance
uh was not making significant progress
uh and thrashers said that it was not
good enough in making a real deal if
you're figuring a conservative majority
so the independent experts say that i
will talk about latest performance with
our next guest lisa nandy i'm keen to
talk about the conservative performance
with you because as you know it's not
just labor you know it's the lib dems
who took a lot of seats
and i'm going to quote an impartial
observer if you like i'll quote the
daily mail
this is uh the daily mail this is what
would success look like at the local
elections for the conservatives and
labor and you can see there in the top
left corner more than 350 losses they're
clocking up as a disaster for the
conservatives yes but look what people
vote in a set of midterm local elections
and what they vote when you choose a
government in general election are two
wholly different things
this is this is what the daily mail
claim that would be a disaster for in
these local elections for the
conservatives what would be the word you
would use to describe them mixed bag
with a mixed bag challenging
you a bit complacent here well no i i'm
i'm sophie i'm not i'm pointed to the
area as well we've done better than
expected um even in london which was a
very difficult set of results for us
there's areas like the croydon merrily
and there's areas like um harlow uh
where we've uh uh uh and and and other
areas where we're actually it has been
uneven uh i i don't think you can take a
a um single view other than to say
london under kiestama looks very much a
metropolitan party which has got appeal
in london but not beyond to the rest of
the country
what we're going to be focusing on this
week is what our plans are to
drive up uh the economy protect the cost
of living we're going to be talking
about aggregate reform in the
agricultural sector innovation to create
cheaper healthier food we're going to be
talking about areas where britain has a
real comparative advantage tech
financial services does there need to be
a bit of a research you think then in
the queen speech i don't think it's a
reset look clearly when you have midterm
local elections there's a lot of protest
votes out there there's a message that
we misheed particularly about not
focusing on westminster but focusing on
them the cost of living problem uh
challenge is going to be there for the
next year do you accept you need to do
more on the cost of living well look
we're doing a huge amount but we've got
22 billion pounds of support that's
going in we've got um
uh uh the uh uh the the um extra money
that's going to be coming through in
july with the national insurance
threshold do you expect you need to do
we are doing work so i'm saying in july
the national insurance threshold we
raise that's extra money in people's
pockets um
we've got the council tax relief uh the
energy bills relief but what i was the
point i was making earlier if you look
at the the kinds of things we're going
to be talking about on the economy in
the weeks ahead from agriculture to
financial services and tech all areas
with a great comparative advantage we're
the ones the conservative government
with a plan to drive up the job creating
wealth that we need those businesses to
create which also provides the tax
revenue that we're funneling in through
this 22 billion package to help people
who are generally finding it hard to
make ends meets labor under kirsten
we're going to spend the less the rest
of the week talking about the curry menu
and the beer
that he did or didn't have up in in
durham we are the ones with a plan to
address these cost of living challenges
um i want to just have a look at how the
conservatives are doing in the south now
sure because obviously you know one of
the big threats for you is the apparent
resurgence of the lib dems in the south
now this is the uh sky news analysis
it's the average change in vote share
in the south it's the top one there you
can see down 5.9 in the south the lib
dems of course up in the south and i
know you want to talk about labor but
i'm not interested in talking about
labor at this point we can talk about
labor with labor right this is about the
lib dems and the conservatives in the
south
your seats in the south yep if we had
swings like this you'd lose your seat
the next election look is going to be a
tough fight for me in my seat um
although actually i'll just point out in
the council we still have more seats
than the liberal democrats on that
council what you're seeing here and the
lib dems have often done it history
shows they're a repository for some
protests vote midterm and although you
don't want to talk about labour that's
precisely because they were doing so
poorly in the rest of england outside
london um but what people want us to see
is get focused on those things that i
talked about
and that's why the plans that we're
talking about to drive up uh innovation
uh in the tech the agricultural sector
and financial services doesn't just
create the well-paid jobs of the future
it creates the tax revenue so that those
that are really feeling the pinch we can
provide that extra support we're the
ones with the plan and that's what we're
going to be talking about do you think
that might be a few weeks focusing on
the red wall
you've taken your eye
of what's happening in your blue wall in
traditional
southern conservative heartlands like
your own i've always said it's a balance
you've got to knit an alliance between
the aspirational working and middle
classes but that's what we're focused on
and that's why uh we're the ones i said
with the plan for the cost of living uh
whether it's the
universal credit taper um you're spoken
about this we have but we're the ones
with the plan we're going to be talking
about that this week whereas i think
you're going to find kirsten wrapped up
in beer gate and durham and the double
standards on the labour party okay i'm
going to we're getting off that i don't
want to ask you about kiss dahmer
because i think you do want to talk
about it which is what i don't know
you've referenced it twice but it's the
contrast so
do you think that kirsten needs to
resign now that he's being investigated
by the police which is what he said uh
boris johnson of course and richie
sooner should do well sophie it's the
rank double standards that drives people
crazy he needs to fess up and answer all
of the
holes in the account that he gave of
that beer and curry
event in durham but frankly i'm not
focused on that and that's why i wanted
to draw the contrast what we're focused
on what this government is focused on is
the measures we're taking on the economy
on tech on the agricultural sector our
farmers brilliant innovation to be done
there financial services to drive up the
well-paid jobs of the future but also
and this is where only the conservatives
offer a plan for a dynamic economy
that's just great tax revenue
i'm not getting into all that because
frankly i'll tell you the thing i heard
on the doorstep loud and clear they want
politicians focused on their issues okay
not westminster but what i would say
about it is kirsten looks like i'm
afraid uh someone who's gauged in
complete hypocrisy complete double
standards and i don't think he's going
to get past that until he gives a proper
account of what happened in durham okay
i mean labour had said that they have
explained what happened in durham and
they said that they're very very
confident that they unlike the prime
minister they won't be found to have
broken the law but as you say let's talk
about other issues that people are uh
interested about now i spoke to david
simmons the conservative mp uh earlier
this week he said the number one issue
on the doorstep was partygate and the
prime minister's conduct and he spoke
about how frustrated he was that the
actions of one individual were coming up
and that councillors had been lost as a
result
and he said that frankly you know he's
gonna be listening to what the prime
minister says and working out whether or
not he has confidence in his leadership
going forward how worried are you
that there will be conservative mps
thinking look hang on a minute we might
be putting in those letters and no
confidence well i don't think so i mean
look i respect all of um
my colleagues and they you know they
make their points and i also feel for
the conservative candidates that lost
their seats um or didn't win their seats
i had one who missed out by just 12
votes which is um very frustrating i
feel full of them but the reality is i
think coming through these local
elections there was no cut through for
labour and kier stammer and what we've
got to do as a team yeah then i get it
but what we've got to do as a team from
our councillors or our mps to our
government and with the leadership of
the pm is get focused on those bread and
butter issues people care about and
that's why don't you think though sorry
that's why i come back to what we're
going to be talking about over the next
month how to drive up the well-paid jobs
of the future but also critically if
you've got a dynamic economy to pay for
the tax revenue that's going to provide
the support for people with the cost of
living that's the crucial issue we're
talking about it none of the other
parties are talking about it i just
wonder if you know people like david
simmons listening to your interview
saying that oh yeah these results were a
mixed bag they're going to think the
people in cabinet just don't get it
look i i saw it seeing it for myself we
had difficult results in elm bridge uh
in the home counties they were but i
also think we need to uh be sober about
this we need to recognize that midterm
elections are difficult uh and and
critically that the labour party has had
very little cut through uh outside
london so so there's a job to do but
that job is not engaged in naval gazing
in westminster it's about addressing the
policy platform of everything we're
doing on the economy on jobs and on the
cost of living and that's what you're
going to hear that's what the government
is going to be setting out in the weeks
ahead is boris johnson still
an asset
electorally for the conservative i'm
confident that he can and will win the
next election but that's not something
that you just deserve you've got to back
it up and that's why we come back to the
measures that we're going to be talking
about on the economy also on the nhs um
on social care
and but critically the relief that only
the conservatives with a dynamic economy
can provide people who are feeling the
pinch of the cost of living you won't
get that with the others so we'll hear
boris johnson will lead the conservative
party into the next election then yes
okay dominic rob thank you very much
indeed good to talk to you
now we've been talking about those
difficult election results for
conservatives or a mixed bag depending
on your uh perspective there and we're
going to talk about labour's performance
with our next guest as well
but there are also as we were discussing
some questions about the future of
kirsten leadership because durham police
are investigating whether he broke
covered rules by having a curry with
party workers after a day of campaigning
well the shadow leveling up secretary
lisa nandy joins us now from salford
thank you very much for being with us as
i said we will get to those local
election results in just a moment but
first let's talk about keir stammer more
allegations in the newspapers this
morning
the sunday times claiming that sources
say kistama didn't do work after eating
as he claimed the mail on sunday he's
got a leaked memo which it claimed shows
the event and the curry was planned
in advance this dinner in miners hall
with mary foy at the air candidate
now labour of course say no rules are
broken they're happy to answer that any
questions so can you just just tell us
exactly
exactly what happened you know was the
event planned in advance was work done
afterwards what actually went on
well i think this note the operations
note that the mail on sunday has got
hold of and demonstrates exactly what
went on was exactly what kierstarma said
went on he went on a work visit
he um stopped to eat at various times
during the day as was um factored into
the work visit
and then he finished the work visit and
he went back to his hotel
i think the this the last few weeks
we've seen an absolutely desperate
attempt to sling mud at the labour
leader and various members of the labour
party and it is frankly absurd of the
tories to claim that this in any way
equates to a prime minister who was
under investigation by the police for 12
separate gatherings which included
karaoke parties bringing your own bottle
parties um
pub quizzes
suitcases full of wine being smuggled
through the back door and the prime
minister lied about that he denied that
they happened he denied that he was
there he came clean and he laughed about
it kierstarma went on a work visit and
had a break to eat the idea that this is
the same sort of thing is just a sign of
a government that is tired is desperate
and is completely out of ideas that
spends more time slinging mud at the
labour party than working out how
they're going to deal with pensioners
who are now struggling so much to heat
their homes that they're having to get
on buses in order to avoid the cold it's
about time that this government just
gave up with this desperate attempt and
went for the sake of this country
okay well let's just put to one side any
comparisons with boris johnson or what
happened in number 10 downing street
let's just put that to one side
kirsten was being investigated by the
police about whether or not he broke the
law if they find that he broke the law
should he resign
well i'm not going to get into that
because it's i'm absolutely confident
that he hasn't broken the law he was
investigating you get into it
genuinely sorry to interrupt you but i i
am struggling to understand why nobody
will engage in this legitimate question
when kirsten is literally under
investigation by the police if you're so
confident i understand that you know if
labour says we're absolutely confident
no rules were broken if they were of
course he'll resign but you know why
just be clear on what that is i don't
understand
because it lends legitimacy to something
that is completely and utterly absurd
that is a desperate attempt by the
government to deflect from the fact that
darren police are in the highest
inflation rate in a generation and
people are struggling to survive and i'm
just i'm not going to entertain it
because i'm absolutely confident that no
rules were broken not least because this
was investigated last time the
conservatives tried to sling mud at us
and kirsten was found to be completely
in the clear this is a guy who
self-isolated six times during the
pandemic i don't know a single other
person who did that he is mr rules he
does not break the rules he was the
director of public prosecutions not
somebody who goes around tearing up
rules when it suits him in stark
contrast to the prime minister i have to
say i think this desperate attempt to
sling mud will fall flat but i think
we'll see more of this as we get closer
to a general election
the one thing that the conservatives
don't want to talk about is what is
actually happening to people in this
country right now and that's what we're
focused on the easiest way to shut down
these questions and to focus on the
issues you want is just to give a
straight answer about what would happen
if durham police find mr rules did break
the rules and we know of course why
we're talking about this because he has
been as you say uh very strong in
criticizing the government and then
calling on them to resign i just want to
look at a tweet from kirstama at the end
of january
after months of denials the prime
minister is now under criminal
investigation for breaking his own
lockdown laws he needs to do the decent
thing and resign now the crucial thing
about this is the date this is before
any fines were issued
your leader is now under investigation
for breaking lockdown laws surely in his
if you'll have his own standards applied
to him then kirsten needs to resign just
for being under investigation
but so if you look i've already answered
that question that that tweet that
called for boris johnson to resign was a
time when the prime minister was under
investigation for 12 separate gatherings
at downing street which he denied for
months had even happened let alone that
he was there and only came clean when he
was caught red-handed
it included karaoke parties bring your
own bottle parties leaving drinks
celebration drinks suitcases full of
wine being smuggled in through the back
door of downing street it is absurd to
equate that to a work
visit with planned breaks to eat it was
not illegal to eat and the longer that
this goes on the reason that we're
talking about it is not because labour
won't answer a straight answer the
reason we're talking about it is because
this government is desperate and they
are throwing mud at the labour party to
deflect from their own failures
the longer that we talk about this and
the less that we talk about that what is
happening to people in the country the
more it fuels the sense that politicians
are out of touch and that's what boris
johnson wants and we're determined not
to allow him to do it okay you're very
clear in your answers you don't think
kerstama will be found
guilty if he does it it's hard to see
how he could potentially stay on this
leader
if the ball to coin afraid
to coin a phrase did come loose at the
back of
the scrum would you fancy have another
crack at the leadership
but i stood to be leader of the labour
party
because i believe that our nations and
regions across britain had been
fundamentally underserved for decades
and we needed to turn that around we
need to get good jobs back into towns
like wigan and across the country and we
need to start putting money in people's
pockets and rebuilding our communities
that's the job that kierstahler has
handed me and for 12 years i've just
watched with absolute desperation as the
tories have visited misery
on people across this country that's why
we've got to get into government and
we've got to turn this around you saw on
thursday that we're starting to do that
that we're starting to fight our way
back in communities where people said it
just wasn't possible only three years
ago and in a couple of years time that
is our responsibility we've got to be in
government get rid of this tired
desperate government and start to turn
around the fortunes of the people in
this country
that sounded a little bit like another
leadership pitch to me
it's it's a pitch to the country that we
need a labour government led by kierst
armour in a couple of years time that is
going to be able to get money back into
people's pockets deal with the immediate
crisis and start to rebuild this country
from the ground up this country cannot
afford more of the conservatives and
there is absolutely no question in my
mind that we can't muck around with
internal debates in the labour party
about who's up and who's down we've got
a leader who even in these last few days
with huge amounts of mud being slung at
him has come out of this showing the
same honesty and character and grit that
he's shown all the way through during
the leadership contest when we're at
competitors and since and we are
absolutely determined that we're going
to stand together
fight together and win the future of
this country together
okay now i am keen to talk about the
local election results we spoke to
dominic rob about the difficult
performance the conservatives had
but i just want to look at labour
because
i accept that you know progress was made
in some areas by labor but you actually
lost vote share in every part of the
country apart from london you also
gained fewer seats than the lib dems and
the green party in england we're looking
at the graph now labour putting on 28
seats in england that's compared to 191
the lib dems and the 61
for the green party and it's pretty
clear isn't it by these results that
people are unhappy with the
conservatives but they're not
necessarily just coming to labour why
not
well three years ago i came on your show
after we just lost our entire labour
base in every nation and region of the
uk
and i think you could see that it was
clear i honestly didn't know if that
break that decisive break that people
had made with us was going to be
permanent it you know these are parts of
the country where like berry like
rottendale like parts of cumbria where
once we were them and they were us and
that break was painful and i wasn't sure
if it was going to be permanent i think
thursday showed the opposite actually i
think it showed that the path back to
power for labour is steep but it doesn't
have to be long and we're making
progress in every region and nation now
in scotland in wales and in and in
england in parts of the country where
you know i watched i watched us lose
labour and peace i lost watched us lose
good people and i wondered if we'd ever
repair that damage we did start to
repair that damage on thursday this was
the turning point for us and i'm
absolutely determined now that this is a
start not the end that we now get on the
front foot to convince people that we're
not just an effective opposition who've
won the right to be heard but we are a
genuine alternative to this awful tory
government that can actually start to
deliver on the things that people care
about like getting money back into
people's pockets through winfield tax
like investing in good jobs in every
community in this country we've started
to set that out but you're going to see
a lot more of that from me from care
from rachel reeves and others over the
next few months do you think labour
needs to be much more bold then in the
policy platform to deal with the cost of
living crisis that's coming down the
road
i think we've been pretty bold so far
we've struck out um at the last um
labour party conference by promising to
invest 28 billion a year every year over
the next decade in good clean jobs in
communities that have seen jobs bleeding
out of those communities for the last 40
years i think you know we have a lot of
debate in the labour party about whether
to be radical i think the key is to be
relevant people need money in their
pockets right now that's why we're
calling for a winful tax on the big oil
and gas producers we need to get that
money back into the pockets not just
because families and businesses are
struggling to survive but because it's a
nonsense to say as michael gove is
saying that you can start to rebuild our
economies and rebuild our high streets
and town centres if people simply don't
have money to spend we we care about the
same things that people in this country
care about they're not getting a hearing
at the moment in the media or the
political debate and it's our job to
make sure that they do
okay i'm keen to talk to you about the
situation in northern ireland as well
with shin fein uh winning that historic
victory
in those assembly elections um now mary
lou macdonald the president of sinfain
has already started talking about the
possibility of a border pole saying a
referendum could be possible within a
five-year time frame
what is the labor party's position on a
border pole in northern ireland
well look we're we believe in the united
kingdom we're not we're not neutral
about that we we
fought for and will strive for and argue
for the future of the united kingdom for
as long as we exist we respect the good
friday agreement and we would
play our role in government as an honest
broker in that but look i think these
elections in northern ireland are
historic and they are significant it's
very clear that people were voting
for change in the last um in the last
set of elections but that does not
equate to voting to
trigger a border poll the good friday
agreement is absolutely clear that there
has to be
a clear majority for that in northern
ireland before that is triggered and i
don't think that those conditions have
in any sense been met most of the major
parties including sinn fein fought these
elections on the cost of living crisis
that is engulfing people in northern
ireland just as it's engulfing people
across the united kingdom we'll support
chimpane to
in their aim to get the executive up and
running as quickly as possible they hope
to do that next week and then to start
focusing on the things that they won
this election on which is the cost of
living crisis and getting money back
into people's pockets and just finally
there's some real concerns about the
ability to actually form an executive at
all with the dep
saying that they're prepared to you know
collapse the paracham arrangement refuse
to join an elect an executive until uh
the northern ireland protocol is dealt
with now dominick robert earlier on the
show said that it needs to be dealt with
as soon as possible what do you think
needs to happen
and we've long been calling for a
veterinary agreement that would help to
break down some of those borders and
barriers that currently exist because of
the northern ireland protocol that boris
johnson negotiated
i think on a broader point you know
at any time in the history of northern
ireland when recent history when there's
been a problem it has usually fallen to
the british prime minister to try to use
his or her personal authority to bring
sides together and to negotiate through
this the difficulty that we find
ourselves in now is that boris johnson
is not seen as an honest broker he is
the person who helped to write the the
architecture of this problem rather than
resolve it i think the key over the next
couple of weeks for the government is
that they've got to get on and resolve
these issues around the northern ireland
protocol because at the moment i have to
say the lack of trust in the prime
minister himself is part of what is
fueling this crisis in northern ireland
so get that agreement in place yes and
the nuts and bolts of it but also boris
johnson has a lot of work to do i think
to prove to people in northern ireland
that he can be trusted okay lisa nandy
thank you very much for being on the
program today
thank you
well as we've been talking about a lot
on the program today one of the most
significant if not the most
consequential of all uh outcomes of
thursday's elections will be in northern
ireland where shin fein of course got
the highest share of the vote and also
the largest number of assembly seats for
the first time
well there is nobody better to tell us
about what that all means than our
senior island correspondent david
blevins who joins us now live thank you
so much for being on the program today
uh david so how long have they got to
form a government and how is northern
ireland governed if that executive can't
be formed
well until two years ago sophie they
would have had just eight days to form a
government before the new assembly would
have effectively collapsed but because
that system had resulted in so much stop
start politics in northern ireland the
frequent collapse or suspension of the
assembly a new agreement was made you
will remember in january 2020 by the
then northern ireland secretary julian
smith and the irish foreign affairs
minister simon covney it was the
agreement that saw stormont come back to
life after a three-year hiatus at that
point with arlene foster and michelle
o'neill sharing power as first and
deputy first minister that agreement
gives more space for them to try and
solve their problems 24 weeks so six
months effectively and there's a lot of
rumor i have to say whispering in dup
circles that they're going to keep
pushing for changes on the northern
ireland protocol that that controversial
border in the irish sea and if they
manage to achieve that
don't rule out the possibility that the
democratic unionists would then allow
this assembly to collapse triggering a
fresh election perhaps in december it
wouldn't be the first time that northern
ireland's had two elections in quick
succession but that is a risky business
for the dup if they choose that route
given that many people here are more
concerned about things like the cost of
living than they are in the
constitutional question of northern
ireland's place in the united kingdom
uh really interesting to hear you talk
about that and we did of course talk
about that with dormant rav as well the
possibility of the whole thing being
collapsed over concerns over the
northern ireland protocol i mean he
seemed to acknowledge that the uk
government needs to move and change it
in some ways what do you think the dp
would need to hear from the queen's
speech next week
well
so jeffrey donaldson says he needs
action not words and that's because they
have lost trust in this government
remember boris johnson came to northern
ireland when theresa may was prime
minister addressed the dup conference
and told them no british prime minister
could ever countenance a border in the
irish sea between great britain and
northern ireland and then a year later
as prime minister himself he agreed to
the northern ireland protocol
establishing a border in the rsc and
ever since has criticized the eu for
really implementing what was agreed now
that tory government will say the eu is
implementing it politically and with no
flexibility but the reality is
that uh mr rabb's comments would suggest
this government doesn't understand
something the fact that of the 90 people
just elected to the new northern ireland
assembly 54 of them are in favor of the
protocol being implemented perhaps with
some changes
only 36
are opposed to the northern ireland
protocol so actually if this government
takes unilateral action to scrap the
protocol for example they may actually
make the business of attempting to form
apartheid government here more difficult
okay david thank you very much for uh
the explanations great to talk to you
this morning david blevins there
now as we were discussing one of the
biggest concerns for the conservatives
after thursday's elections will be the
ground loss to the liberal democrats in
the south and it means there might be
some nervous conservative mps ahead of
the next election maybe even dominic rob
himself but just how confident should
the lib dems be feeling well
we're now joined by the party's deputy
leader david cooper who joins us now
congratulations on your results how
confident are you that they could be
replicated at a general election
well we have had a fantastic set of
election results as you say across
england scotland and wales
and we've seen a real revival in rural
areas such as somerset and cumbria and
we've made real inroads into new areas
in what we call our blue wall area
places like west oxfordshire and
wimbledon and eastern walton and
harpenden places where liberal democrats
are currently in second place and where
we want to target conservative mps at
the next general election of course we
never ever take votes for granted um and
so we will be we will be working very
hard uh over the coming months and years
to ensure that we can win the support
and votes of people in these areas
um well you've of course got the tibetan
and huntington by-election coming up
that one triggered by the resignation of
neil paris for watching pornography
dominic robb admitted he actually faces
a tough fight in his seat as well at the
next general election in those two
places specifically are you confident
that we could still lived mmps
well certainly in eastern walton which
is dominic raab seat we have a very
strong local government base now and
we're hopeful that that is a seat that
we might be able to win at the next
general election um and in tiverton and
honeton i think you can see that really
across the whole of the south west
actually liberal democrats have a very
strong history of being the key
challenges to the conservatives in that
area and we are starting to see a
revival there and if there's one message
we can take from these local elections
is that people are really fed up of
being taken for granted in both of these
places and many more places as well
whether it's the party scandals whether
it's misleading parliament whether it's
the cost of living crisis or running our
health services into the ground people
are really sick and tired of being taken
for granted
now of course it's important to you know
qualify some of what we've been saying
by the fact that these local elections
people do vote very differently in a
general election tends to be for bigger
parties um but what the results do point
towards you know according to the sky
news analysis as well is a hung
parliament with neither labor or um the
conservatives managing to get a majority
would the lib dems be prepared to go
into a coalition
well the outcome of the next general
election is entirely in the hands of the
voters we don't even know when the next
general election is going to be we don't
know what the mood or the state of the
country is going to be and but the
message that we've got from this these
local elections is that people are
really really scared about the cost of
living emergency that is happening just
to just come in again just to come in
again on
the possibility of the coalition you
won't rule out doing a coalition either
with the conservatives or with labour
then
um our number one priority for the
liberal democrats is ousting this
conservative government we have no
interest in doing a coalition with this
conservative government at all and we
have said that we are second place to
the conservatives in around 80 seats
around the country and those are the
areas where we will be targeting
conservative mps and we will play a role
in ousting them but right now
coalition with labor
look the outcome of the next general
election is in the hands of the voters
right now what voters have been telling
us over the last few days in the run-up
to the local elections is that there is
a cost of living emergency which is why
we want to see an emergency vat cut in
the queen's speech they are fed up with
their health services being driven into
the ground people can't see their gp
just to be crystal clear that you won't
rule out a coalition with the labour
party
liberal democrats have said that we want
to win as many seats as possible off the
conservatives at the next general
election and one way or another we would
like to play a role in ousting this
conservative government it's far too
soon to say what that might look like or
how that might work but we would want to
play a role in ousting this conservative
government that's our number one
priority okay i think reading between
the lines that's actually quite clear
and
just finally i want to ask you a
question about kierstarma um
if he is found and to have broken covert
laws by durham police if he's issued
with a fixed penalty notice does he need
to resign
well i think it's absolutely vital for
public trust that these allegations are
investigated
i'm sure they will be investigated
thoroughly and i hope they'll be
investigated quickly as well but what i
think is really important to remember is
that there was only one man who wrote
these rules these rules that separated
families at these key moments of of
children's births and people's deaths
and really it was boris johnson who
wrote those rules he was on tv screens
every single night telling us we had to
follow them or people's lives would be
lost and it's he it's boris johnson who
wrote the rules broke the rules and is
now subject to three different
investigations
okay daisy cooper thank you very much
for being on the program today
later keeper there
well let's turn back to the conservative
party in the performance
in those local elections because there
will of course be plenty of conservative
mps who are looking uh forwards in
considering uh whether or not boris
johnson's the right person to lead the
party how the party resets itself
after some of those disappointing
results across the country let's talk
now to tom tugan hat the chairman of the
foreign affairs select committee at
shall we he holds the seat of tonbridge
and mallinger ian kent
dominic robb
described the results as a mixed bag is
that a bit complacent
no i don't think it's complicated i
think it's a pretty accurate description
but it's a it's a pretty big
blow for 400 and
something of our our friends who have
stood as conservative councillors and i
tell you i was campaigning in places
like cumberland and wandsworth and
people like ravi govinda who have
devoted frankly a lifetime to serving
the people of wandsworth and people like
john malenson up in in in carlisle have
done similarly
for our community there is phenomenal
you know it's a real it's a real tragedy
i just want to talk specifically about
what's happening in the south um you
know you represent tombridge and malling
you know i mean kent it's exactly what
these
were the conservatives did badly uh
neighbouring tumbridge worlds for
example losing control of that council
election just looking now at the
conservatives losing support in the
south down 5.9 percent that average
change in vote share
in the south and mainly at the expense
of the liberal democrats why do you
think so many people in southern england
are turning against the conservatives
well you spoke to david simmons and that
came up a bit but i have to say one of
the things that came up even more for me
in the south of england was planning and
you know we need to address the fact
that the garden of england cannot become
the patio of england we need to make
sure that communities in across the
united kingdom have a say in what's
built near them by the way for many
people that means building more because
people want their friends and children
and family to come and live near them
but people do need to have control of
their lives and i think that's one of
the things that these elections have
really pushed hard as well because a lot
of the issues that have come forward
have not been the national issues that
you have been quite understandably
talking about a lot of them have been
down to local issues i mean i can
certainly tell you that in places like
tunbridge wales a lot of the issues have
been down to very local planning
decisions which people feel have gone
out of their control
at the same time though i just wonder
you know i speak to david gork yesterday
as well and he was saying that he's got
concerned that by effectively leaning in
to some of the issues that he believes
are relevant in the red wall seats
brexit culture wars boris johnson has
been alienating some of the voters in
his more traditional blue shires if you
like do you think that that is true
well i mean you can you you can talk
about different emphasis if you like i
mean i think the british people across
the entire uh united kingdom want the
same thing from leadership they want
integrity they want clarity and honesty
i mean i don't think these are i don't
think these are red wall or or south
east or northeast or whatever issues
these are national issues uh and i think
people want the same but i think
in all honesty just to come integrity
and honesty is partygate coming up quite
a lot then
well it's coming up a lot in parliament
look i mean there's some people who've
taken money off uh chinese uh people
who've now been known to be chinese
agents that's the lib dems there's some
people who are now being investigated
for various different things that's
labor that you know this is going across
and frankly a lot of us have had enough
of it you know it's not that hard uh to
remember that the people we all serve
the british people not ourselves and and
i do find it somewhat frustrating
sometimes to hear the cant from other
sides of the chamber and to watch what's
going on but it's also you know daisy
quite understandably said these boris's
rules on covert well she voted for them
i didn't hear her opposition during that
this was a pretty much the entire
parliament voted for it only a few of us
were built
i think daisy's point to be fair wasn't
about the covered rules themselves but
the fact that boris johnson made the
rules and then broke the covered rules
and that actually voted the question
that i asked you the question that i
asked you was whether or not that's
coming up on the doorstep so i'm not
totally sure why we're talking about
chinese agents and the lib dems but you
know
because
an issue on the doorstep has
particularly been
so you asked me about integrity and
you're right to ask me about integrity
because it really matters serving the
british people properly and remembering
that this is a duty and a service not
you know some sort of joyride is
absolutely essential
but that applies across the entire house
and i'm afraid what has been so
frustrating in the last few years is how
many people across the whole house seem
to have forgotten that i'm not defending
anybody i'm not attacking anybody in
particular i'm just pointing out that
this is something that has become an
issue for the entire parliament and i
think we need to sort it out
is boris johnson still an electoral
asset to the conservative party
well it depends on the voter i mean
there are plenty of people who still
support him very closely and you know uh
in tunbridge morning i can tell you i
get letters in support of him i get
letters against him and that's not
exactly surprising he's always been a
divisive character and he's always been
somebody who's communicated his message
extremely clearly and you can choose
which one of those uh skills or which
one of those aspects you you think is
most beneficial but you know we can
focus if you like on on the internal
politics but the most important thing
that happened on thursday wasn't boris
johnson the most important thing that
happened on thursday was the result in
northern ireland and the bank of
england's announcement that we may well
be going into recession and i have to
say those are the two things that are
going to be occupying my mind as we go
forward because holding the union
together and protecting our economy
therefore protecting the british people
in both senses i think it's absolutely
fundamental so what do you want to see
from the government in relation to those
as you say extremely important issues uh
next week when the queen's speech
happens
well the first one on on northern
ireland i think it's listen to the
people of northern ireland you know we
have had a very very uh long-standing
principle embedded in various different
elements of the anglo-irish agreement
and the friday agreement that the
consent of the people of northern
ireland is the paramount uh decision you
know decider of of the outcome of
different uh events there and so we do
need to listen and that means listening
to people on the east west trade and on
the north south trade now i think we can
resolve this but it requires goodwill
and cooperation certainly uh uh across
across the island of ireland and across
the european union and across the united
kingdom and i think lowering the tension
is extremely important there the second
element on the economy i think there's
an awful lot that we can do i mean i
wasn't a supporter of the rise in
national insurance and i think there are
many other areas where we should be
looking at how we can ease the burden
on the british people because as we go
into a period where the bank of england
is telling us there's going to be slow
growth and the bank of england is going
to tell is telling us already that
inflation is running we're about to run
at somewhere near 10 and various banks
are telling us in private that the for
the lower down and for those poorer in
our community
those who are struggling more in our
community it's already running higher
than that 10 15
you know we really do need to be looking
at this because this is about serving
the entire community and making sure
that people have what they need to
survive what's going to be likely to be
a very difficult time
you've previously said that you would
run for the leadership if boris johnson
was to go
is that still your position
well i've made it very clear um folks i
think i'm the only person who's made it
very clear that i think serving our
country at every level is is an enormous
honor you know i've been lucky enough to
serve in uniform to serve as a diplomat
and now serving in parliament and i hope
you know i'll be able to serve in many
different ways and one of the ways of
course i'd like to serve uh our country
as uh you know
in the position that gives me influence
over the things that i think really
matter of course of course that's what i
want to do i i
came into parliament because i thought
that ideas matter that our country
matters in our communities matter and i
hope to serve a long time yet
i like you said in january as you were
mentioning that i think it's a position
of absolute integrity to say that of
course you should offer yourself to the
electorate if you think you can do it of
course you should talk to colleagues and
see if you can get a group together and
if you can get a group together you
should go for it have you been talking
to colleagues not particularly no i mean
the the the real thing i've been doing
at the moment is dealing with the issues
that you're about to talk about when you
speak to the finnish ambassador i've
spent an awful lot of time speaking to
people in sweden and indeed finland and
across uh the the viking territories if
you like the northern uh the northern
states uh to uh discuss both the nato
element that i hope you're gonna be
discussing with the finnish ambassador
which i must say i'm very very pleased
that the finns have taken this decision
or look likely to take this decision but
i'm also talking about different ways of
working with our european partners you
know for example you know youth mobility
schemes are not specifically covered by
the european union we can have them
separately the canadians have a separate
one with sweden why can't we you know
there's various elements that i'd like
to look at working with different
countries in different ways because i
think international outreach is
absolutely essential to our future and i
think britain is uniquely placed to be a
network power that brings people
together so i'm afraid that's where i've
been putting my focus
okay uh tom tugging thank you very much
indeed for being on the program today
tom two can have that
well we're just talking there about the
uh interview with the finnish ambassador
that we're about to uh go to now and we
were of course saying you know the war
in ukraine and the utter misery uh it's
creating is more than two months old now
the ukrainian president says that any
peace deal must involve russian forces
totally pulling back to pre-invasion
positions as the latest resistance in
mario paul seems on the verge of defeat
and of course it means that other
countries in europe are reassessing
their own security with sweden and
finland apparently on the brink of
historic applications to join
nato
we're joined now by finland's ambassador
to the uk that is uh yuko sukasari thank
you very much for being with us
so there has been reports that may the
12th is the date that finland will
decide to apply to nato is that right
well that date is important
and thank you for having me in the
program
the president of finland has said that
by the
may 12th he will make his opinion public
we started this democratic process
almost immediately after
after the russian invasion of ukraine
and it has been a very
um thorough parliamentary procedure with
a report from the government through the
parliament on the options
and
indeed applying for nato membership is
one of the options so on the 12th
things are moving they have been moving
of course already before that with
various political parties stating their
opinions and all indeed mps we have 200
members of parliament coming out to the
public and saying openly what they
think about it
you've obviously never felt the need to
apply to join nato before
what's changed
i have to go a little bit back on
history actually almost a thousand years
we were part of the swedish kingdom for
six centuries
then we were part of the western empire
as an
as an um very autonomous
grand duchy so we have throughout
all of our history being between east
and the west and finland has often been
sort of dragged into conflicts that we
had very little
ownership of that that had very little
to do with finland but more with the big
power politics
and that is why the finns have had a
very pragmatic approach to military
alignment we haven't seen it as a
necessity necessity we might have been
even suspicious about it but now with
the um invasion of ukraine by russia
which we
completely completely condemn and wish
the finnish population doesn't
understand at all and doesn't accept uh
the the climate the political climate
and the popular opinion has changed
um this week your foreign ministry has
said of russian army helicopter violated
finland's airspace how concerned are you
about
aggression from russia
when it comes to violations of airspace
we have had plenty of those before
during the past years when we always
react to them and we demand an
explanation
um that is not new uh we are also quite
prepared for any other type of
influence or influence attempts from
russia during the process of application
if we do to decide to start it we have
invested in our preparedness and i don't
mean only defense
but the sort of holes of society
approach comprehensive security for
decades and i think we are quite well
prepared for different types of uh
influence including cyber hybrid uh or
indeed uh violations of our of our
territory
there's obviously a border between
finland and russia we've all seen the
atrocities that have happened
in ukraine
frankly if you're not a member of nato
is finland feeling vulnerable
i wouldn't say vulnerable is the word we
are concerned we are very concerned for
the security structure of europe that we
have built our security around
but as i said we have been investing in
our own national defense for decades we
have quite a robust defense force both
the army the air force and the navy so
in that sense we are not
overly
worried
what we are concerned about is what this
this attack and this war will mean
to the european security structure in
the future and therefore we have taken
this opportunity to consider our route
forward and we shall see where where the
parliamentary and the democratic
decisions lead us
are you confident that if you did apply
to join nato that you would be accepted
reports that the croatian president
saying that he would actually veto
any application
we are following very carefully the
discussion in different major countries
and
embassies including my own have been
tasked to find out what the political
climate in each and every member state
is for the part of the uk i can say and
that was also uh repeated by tom
tuggenheim just a couple of minutes ago
that
the british report is very clear so we
have absolutely no no concerns about
about britain whatsoever
each member states and there are 30 of
those in nato is a case of its own and
of course we are looking at each and
every one of them but at the moment
i wouldn't say that we have particular
concerns of any of them
what are you prepared to contribute to
nato if you were to become members
certainly we take our memberships in in
any organization very seriously since
other a rule of a nation and a country
we have a strong national defense so i
think our inclusion in nato would
strengthen uh
the security situation around the baltic
sea we are also an extremely solid
democracy the least corrupt country in
the world and in some fields of
technology including
mobile networks uh artificial
intelligence quantum intelligence we are
ahead of the field you might say so i
think we have a lot lots to contribute
and just finally obviously the
importance of nato has really been
highlighted with the war in ukraine but
there has been criticism of nato
previously uh by many different um
people of course um that it's too
aggressive that it's provoked russia by
moving troops do you accept any of those
criticisms of how nato has been
i think we see nato as a defense
alliance and and
of course when you plan for defence you
have to prepare for different
alternatives but i don't think
we uh see in finland see that nato uh
and indeed nato member states can be in
any way blamed for what has happened in
ukraine that was a russian aggression
against a sovereign neighboring state uh
i'm completely unwarranted and and i'm
called
okay thank you very much for being on
the program today really interesting to
talk
to you there you curse you kasari thank
you
thank you
sophie well it's been a busy show for us
sir today after a busy couple of days
with those local elections as well a
quick reminder our weekly podcast is
available every week highlights of the
interviews and some thoughts from the
teams here i think there'll be quite a
lot of thoughts to be honest i i feel
like i've been just in the in the mind
of those uh local election results and
i've you know be quite nice to kind of
decompress on the podcast in a moment
that will be available wherever you get
your podcast from well that is it for
this week's saferidge on sunday in a
moment after the break we'll be running
through today's interview seeing what we
learned with our deputy political editor
sam coats thank you very much for
joining us this sunday morning
[Music]
okay let's go
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome to sophie ridge the
take where we'll reflect on what we've
just heard over the last hour focusing
of course on the election results the
implications of sinn fein winning in
northern ireland and big eight and among
our guests were the deputy prime
minister dominic raab the shadow
leveling up secretary lisa nandy and the
deputy leader of the lib dems daisy
cooper
well it has been quite a show but also
quite a few days i've been brought a cup
of tea in the break by the floor manager
which i feel is quite needed to kind of
decompress lightly
after
what's been going on we're also joined
of course by our deputy political sam
coats who's on hand to help us analyze
the interviews and also the results sam
i mean you've had quite a few days as
well haven't you um
where do you think we are after the
local elections then what's your main
sort of takeaways
well elections always throw up surprises
they always prove to be significant
perhaps in ways that we didn't expect
and the agenda is extremely long this
morning
first up those election results really
now bring the question of the union of
the united kingdom right back into the
fore
you've got the twin issues in northern
ireland of whether or not they could in
the next few years should elections be
going in the right way uh be a
border pole in other words the question
would be put to the people of northern
ireland and the republic of ireland
whether or not northern ireland should
be reunited with the republic
and
or whether it should stay part of the
united kingdom allied with that
intertwined with that is now the
question of what happens with the
northern ireland protocol so those two
things are in are in the agenda in
northern ireland then you move to
scotland
up in scotland what was really striking
is it was again the nationalists for the
fifth set of local elections in a row uh
who put on seats really quite a
phenomenal uh task for uh for an
organization for a political party
that's 15 years in government
and then i think the
local election results in england and
wales threw up
more surprises we sat in the studio that
you're in on wednesday sophie and i said
then i just wonder whether for labor and
the conservatives both party leaders end
up coming out with a bloody nose uh and
frankly for various reasons for various
different results around the country the
tories looking like their heartlands are
somewhat straining that they were losing
support there for labor uh for its
inability to make bigger progress i
think that kierstama and boris johnson
have emerged with a bloody nose so it's
it's been really quite uh quite a
revealing few days and a revealing set
of results yeah like you say sam it's
almost like you just don't know what to
talk about because there are so many
things that have such big consequences
and we'll be with sam of course as the
program goes on but it does feel like
the place that we should start is on
what happens with northern ireland
because there are some really really big
questions of course uh thrown up by
those set results not least if the dup
are even prepared to enter a parish
sharing arrangement at all or if they're
prepared to collapse the executive
because they're so happy unhappy i
should say about that northern ireland
protocol well it was the first thing
that i spoke to uh the deputy prime
minister dominic rav about he said the
government is focused on unlocking the
problems with the northern ireland
protocol he wants to see it fixed
quickly otherwise there won't be
stability in northern ireland
we prefer to get it resolved through
negotiation that's why
we've been through a protracted period
to try and get it fixed through
negotiation but of course as you know
there are measures that we can take um
to make sure that we deal with the
problem we can't put it off and it's
clear now and in fact if anything the
outcome in northern ireland from those
elections makes it clear it can't be put
off and you say it can't be put off what
kind of time frame are we talking about
here well i don't want to jump the gun
because that will lead all the headlines
i think it needs to be dealt with very
responsibly but we've been talking about
are you talking weeks we're talking
months
no longer than that 58
fully of people voted either for parties
who support the union or for parties who
do not support constitutional change and
that is the message from the people of
northern ireland but what is the uk uh
government position on a border pole
well look we don't have an executive um
uh yet
so i feel like in the kind of carefully
couched language that all westminster
politicians use when talking about
northern ireland he's pushing back
slightly on the idea that there could be
a border pole there but i think the
immediate thing in the entree of the
government here in westminster is that
northern ireland protocol because
although you know they're trying to say
it's all about how it's implemented
clearly it is boris johnson's you know
brexit deal that he signed and there
will be some in the dep who feel that
they were mislead by the prime minister
over what that meant well let's bring in
our deputy political editor sam coach
shall we
dominic rob didn't want to be drawn into
how soon it could in his words be fixed
but they're going to have to act quite
quickly on this aren't they
yes tuesday actually will be
a signal of the start of action let me
explain what's going on because uh
politicians don't like to preempt
queen's speeches
but what's essentially been decided by
boris johnson's government is that they
are going to
pick yet another big high-profile angry
fight with the european union again over
the northern ireland deal that boris
johnson stuck as part of his brexit deal
and that will kick off in the queen
speech on tuesday where we understand
her majesty is now very likely to make a
reference to protecting the good friday
agreement in her address to parliament
now that will be code for the beginning
of hostilities effectively
and what the government wants to do is
uh yes try and trigger another round of
talks with the eu but introduce a new
element which is the threat of
legislation that will effectively
scrap the northern ireland protocol
which you know is part of a big
uh treaty that the uk uh
negotiated with the eu's uh meant to be
internationally binding
they would threaten to introduce
domestic legislation simply to ignore
that treaty now we've been through one
of these rounds before about 18 months
ago it was called the internal market
bill britain ended up
backing down it caused enormous tension
friction unhappiness in europe but it
looks as if they're going to put the you
know put the uh
sort of uh press the button on that one
more time a lot of saber-rattling in the
sunday papers this morning lots of
sources close to liz trust maybe it
would seem brave enough quite to come
out and say things on the record
but essentially saying that the eu is
interfering in a the sovereign affairs
of the united kingdom the truth is that
was the brexit deal that boris johnson
struck in order to ensure that there was
no hard border between northern ireland
and the republic of ireland which is of
course inside the european union uh and
allowing there uh to be an exposed
border uh on the north uh flank of the
republic of ireland uh and the price
that uh was paid for that
but it's gonna be messy and
one of the things i thought was most
interesting is that in a later answer
the bit that you just played
dominick rob made clear that he just
didn't think that there was a mandate
further down the track for
essentially a border pole
uh people voting in uh the reunification
of uh the republic of ireland uh because
of the way that people in northern
ireland voted but then you listen to
david blevins sky's island correspondent
and he pointed out that there is not a
majority in the northern ireland
assembly now as elected on thursday to
scrap the protocol which is precisely
the path that essentially this
government is signaling it is prepared
to go down uh sky's david blevins
pointed out that 54 members of the new
northern ireland assembly want to keep
but perhaps change but certainly keep
the northern ireland protocol whether
well 36 new members of the newly elected
members largely the dup want to scrap it
yet this is the path that the
westminster government is about to go
down so expect this to be quite high
wire expect this to be very contested
expect europe to react very very badly
indeed
it's one of those things that some in
some perhaps slightly more cynical
people in number 10 uh hope might keep
some of the uh right flank of the tory
party on board because uh there's
nothing that some of them like more uh
than a dust-up with the eu yeah it looks
like it's coming doesn't he dominic rob
saying that they're prepared to act
unilaterally uh if needed uh thank you
uh very much uh sam yeah sam was saying
after those results it might be uh that
boris johnson's looking for a bit of a
red meat to throw to his party and i
wonder if this could be it
well we were also joined on the program
by the deputy leader of the liberal
democrats daisy cooper of course the
dems performed pretty well in the local
elections particularly against
conservatives in the south of england so
i was keen to find out if the party
would consider a coalition to get into
government
we want to win as many seats as possible
off the conservatives at the next
general election and one way or another
we would like to play a role in ousting
this conservative government it's far
too soon to say what that might look
like or how that might work but we would
want to play a role in ousting this
conservative government that's our
number one priority
i thought that was actually pretty clear
uh to be honest and with these things
often you know you're expecting
politicians to decide to take the
question she didn't exactly directly
answer it but i think reading between
the lines you could see that the lib
dems are see a situation where they
could uh join forces with labor uh in a
hung parliament but not the
conservatives and it does feel like this
is a relevant question even though we're
just talking about local election
results even though a general election
is a long uh way away potentially well
although according to reports boris
johnson could pull the trigger slightly
early and what the results point to more
than anything uh is no party getting a
majority so it does feel like quite a
relevant question to be asking
now we also asked donald trump about the
conservative party's losses at the polls
this weekend and whether kostarma should
resign if he's found to have broken
lockdown rules
i've always said it's a balance you've
got to knit an alliance between the
aspirational working and middle classes
but that's what we're focused on and
that's why
we're the ones as i said with the plan
for the cost of living we're going to be
talking about that this week whereas i
think you're going to find kierstarma
wrapped up in beer gate and dura is the
rank double standards that drives people
crazy he needs to
fess up and answer all of the um holes
in the account that he gave of that beer
and curry
event in durham
let's bring uh sam coats back in at this
point shall we
um sam i have to say that i thought it
was probably a little bit rich for
dominic ram to be you know accusing
labour of being wrapped up in beer gate
and wanting to talk too much about being
he didn't at all even though he brought
her up about three or four times by my
account during the interview
absolutely it was almost like the
deputy prime minister was still in
campaigning mode um there's a lot to
campaign the lord campaign needed by the
conservative party uh because of the
prediction and predicament that they're
in but i just want to focus on that
first uh excerpt the
comments by the liberal democrat deputy
leader um i thought what she said to put
no bones about it was really really
really really important why
right the projections of what uh the
local elections would look like if it
was a national poll uh show that we're
heading towards a hung parliament now
michael thrasher skye's election analyst
has put some numbers on it this morning
he's done so in the sunday times with
colin runnings his uh colleague and
those numbers suggest that the labour
party would be on 35 on the basis of
thursday's results the conservatives
would be on 33
and the liberal democrats would be on 17
uh percent storming result for liberal
democrats i think both the conservatives
and the labour party would be pretty
disappointed with that for one reason
another as we were discussing before but
the point about that is it would be a
hung parliament and in that situation
the liberal democrats possibly along
with the snp the liberal democrats would
be king maker now in the past the
liberal democrats have kept their
council have not said whether or not
they would put a taurean downing street
or a labor uh prime minister in downing
street but there on your show you got an
answer it was an absolutely unambiguous
answer and that answer is we're gonna
we're gonna fight to get rid of the
tories and effectively what that means
although uh unsurprisingly the liberal
democrats don't like spelling it quite
out uh loud like that is you they would
put a labor prime minister kierstarma uh
in downing street in that uh scenario
and that is a game-changing statement
and it means that the conservatives from
now on will absolutely know because uh
the liberal democrats have committed in
public on your show that they will face
a combined opposition trying to get rid
of them so unless they get an overall
majority there is not going to be a
conservative in downing street boris
johnson in downing street after the next
election it matters enormously and that
puts more pressure on the tories and
means that the uh that's why dominic rob
was in campaign mode oh there you go uh
sam really interesting uh to talk as
ever uh time now for a quick break uh
after this break we're going to have
more on those claims about the labour
leader kierstama and how liz and nandy
dealt with them
[Music]
so this is a bit of a moment in time i
think the government here in the uk is
reviewing a 10-year study that it
commissioned into the keeping of
elephants in zoos and the biggest
elephant keeper in britain damien
aspinall of howlitz is sending all his
elephants so 25 of the entire number of
elephants in the united kingdom uh to be
rewilding in kenya the research that
we've undertaken uh explores issues such
as obesity which is widespread mental
distress that elephants suffer which is
widespread
infant mortality which is 40 percent of
elephants born in captivity in the uk
die before the age of five longevity the
fact that they don't live as long as
they would naturally in the wild there's
a whole raft of evidence as to why after
keeping elephants in zoos for
approximately 200 years in this country
um we need to have a profound and
fundamental rethink not tinkering around
the edges baby steps it really is time
for those elephants that can go back to
the wild to go back to the wild and for
those elephants that can't to be retired
to specialized sanctuaries and that's
why we're calling on george eustis the
secretary of state to bring in measures
that would prevent the import of further
elephants would bring the attempted
breeding of elephants and it's a pretty
abysmal story when it comes to the
breeding of elephants bring that to a
close and to help
uh find an alternative future for the
rest of their lives for the elephants
that we currently have
the real catastrophe here is for wild
elephants i mean what what zoos are is
part of the solution and so whilst i
acknowledge some of the facts that that
will's talking about they're spanning
back over 40 years you know modern
progressive zoos
are conservation international ngos
that's why i'm talking to you today from
the eastern cape you know working in a
reserve you know talking about elephant
stocking as well as a whole range of
other species so they are modern
progressive conservation centers uh that
are an integral part of the conservation
of a whole raft of species and those
species can range from
orchids
to snails to birds right through to
elephants you know
and lots of the things that we're doing
in zoos are now pioneering and looking
at the techniques that may well be game
changing and saving for elephants
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello welcome back to safety ridge on
sunday the take where we take you back
through the morning's interviews with
some analysis from me and deputy
political editor
sam coates well the shadow levelling up
secretary lisa nandy was on the program
today discussing of course labour's
election performance but also she found
herself obviously answering questions
about kia stammer and the latest big
eight allegations i asked her if if he
should resign if he's found her broken
covered rules let's hear
it lends legitimately to something that
is completely and utterly absurd
that is a desperate attempt by the
government to deflect from the fact that
we've got the highest inflation rate in
a generation and people are struggling
to survive this is a guy who
self-isolated six times during the
pandemic i don't know a single other
person who did that he is mr rules he
does not break the rules that called for
boris johnson to resign was a time when
the prime minister was under
investigation for 12 separate gatherings
at downing street which he denied for
months had even happened let alone that
he was there and only came clean when he
was caught red-handed
that included karaoke parties bring your
own bottle parties leaving drinks
celebration drinks suitcases full of
wine being smuggled in through the back
door of downing street it is absurd to
equate that to a work
visit with planned breaks to eat it was
not illegal to eat
elise and andy's defense there of
kierstama mr rules as she called him
saying that there was no point even
entertaining the thought about what
would happen if he was found to have
broken the rules because it wasn't going
to happen well i also i couldn't resist
asking at least andy if she'd have
another crack at becoming a labour
leader if an opportunity was to arise
look i stood to be leader of the labour
party
because i believe that our nations and
regions across britain had been
fundamentally underserved for decades
and we needed to turn that around we
need to get good jobs back into towns
like wigan and across the country and we
need to start putting money in people's
pockets and rebuilding our communities
that's the job that kierstahler has
handed me and for 12 years i've just
watched with absolute desperation as the
tories have visited misery
on people across this country
uh it did sound like she was setting her
stall out slightly there uh talking
about why she ran the first time well
let's bring in our deputy political
editor sam coates shall we he's on a
hand to help us analyze some of the
morning's interviews i can see you
grilling there after the leasing handy
uh interview what's your takeaway sam
um you have to understand the context
sophie lisa nandi was already on the
naughty step with kierstama's office
because she had suggested
she didn't think that he should be going
on about partygate quite so much and i
think the leaders office were pretty
cross about that i'm not sure this
morning's interview will have
particularly helped mr rules that's
hardly the most inspiring name you could
uh slap on a leader and then uh
incredibly uh forward-leaning answer
into question your question about
whether or not she'd have another go if
there was a vacancy at the top of the
labour party well i think drew a little
bit of uh sharp intake of breath uh here
in southeast london i have to say even
if she insists she was being completely
loyal lisa nandy always knows what she's
doing but let's return to the substance
uh we are on month five of partygate and
beergate and its different
forms but it remains relevant it
actually remains important there is a
path to kierstarma having to resign that
is if durham police find that he broke
the rules on april 30th 2021 uh at an
event in durham miners hall where there
was curry and bear at the end of the day
of campaigning labor say they didn't
break the rules and it was all uh
completely uh
sort of organized to comply with the
pandemic laws in place at that point now
overnight this subject has returned
because the mail on sunday have the men
on sunday published a memo detailing uh
the day's events and that included a
reference to that curry which perhaps
labour had implied was a spur of the
moment thing actually appears in the
grid now that memo much discussed
on social media and in the papers this
morning now controversially having read
it i actually think it might help
kirsten's legal case even if it causes
some political controversy because it
makes absolutely clear that the
dinner that you saw
the grainy footage of the film footage
of that we've been showing on sky news
was pre-planned as a work event by the
labour party as part of campaigning now
therefore to make the case that it was
socializing
it looked to me became a little bit
harder so perhaps that will play uh in
kierstama's defense uh but uh none of
this is helping the labour party uh uh
just get back on the front foot uh
really good to talk as always sam and as
you say it might be an impact where
darren please clear kirstalma and that
is almost that is all there is to it
well that is it for safety ridge on
sunday after a very busy week we'll see
you next sunday and on wednesday as well
for the take hope you tune in
[Music]